Hello Freak bitches.
One of the most interesting things that I learned from the injury was,
was how,
how your physical health or wellbeing alters your,
uh,
your perception of the world.
Like,
I,
um,
have you ever heard of this study?
They,
they do like the hot and cold cups study where they have someone come in to fill
out a survey,
you know,
that's what they tell them.
And then a person gets in an elevator and they,
uh,
and there's,
there's someone in there like confederate,
an actor is in there that's like,
here I,
my hands are full.
Could you hold this cup for me?
And it's either like a hot cup of coffee or whatever,
or a cold drink and the person says,
sure.
Takes the drink,
goes up the elevator,
gets off,
gives it back to them,
you know,
says buy,
goes in and takes the survey and then afterwards,
and this is what it's actually about.
Afterwards they go,
did you meet anyone?
And the way in.
And I got actually someone I met someone in the elevator and then they'll,
there'll be like,
so uh,
can you,
can you describe that person?
And if they had,
if they had the hot drink,
they'll,
uh,
they were more,
um,
they would more often describe them as being like warm or friendly.
And if they had the cold drink,
they would,
they would describe them as like a cold or distant.
And,
and the idea is,
is that that,
um,
that the,
the way our brains evolved kind of these,
these higher ideas of,
of what like being distant as a personality trait or whatever means he has to be
built over this preexisting kind of,
uh,
five senses kind of software.
And,
um,
and so,
so there's all these metaphors for things.
So you call someone like bright or you say we're having a deep conversation or
someone's shallow.
So a lot of these ways in which we describe life is,
is kind of used through these physical metaphors.
And I remember when I,
when I broke my feet,
I remember thinking the whole fucking world is broken.
Like,
I remember thinking like eyes on eyes going down this mountain for like three,
three hours and I wasn't just worried about my feet eyes also like in the
fucking political system is it?
Like everything just seemed broken like the whole world.
And then I also remember after I got the second surgery,
after the bone infection and stuff and having to change all this,
I remember feeling like,
like something like this nagging feeling that I couldn't get over.
I was like some things like missing from my life.
There's just this deep like whole like somewhere in my soul in my leg.
And then one day I realized I'm like,
oh,
there's a fucking hole in my foot.
There's an actual hole in my feet,
foot.
That's what's missing.
And,
and just how much that,
that your,
your physical senses can alter what your perception of the world is.
The food
denial,
floods and the food jumps out of the ground and under the,
under the,
with,
with uh,
with a series of genuinely enlightened rulers,
or at least pretty close to enlightened real is ruling them.
It all lasts for 3,500 years.
And how did they live?
You'll see everything that they did.
In fact,
until quite recently,
there were no such things as jobs that were trades and crafts and skills and
arts and everybody.
I mean,
yes,
and in Europe,
the combination of an oppressive church and then oppressive nobility kept
everybody,
you know,
immersed in serfdom in one way or another.
But what people actually did with that lives was in some sense or another
transformational,
all of it.
It takes a lot of smarts to be a good peasant.
All of these things that people used to do as a matter of course,
and in Egypt,
you see it,
you see it carved into the walls and everyone thinks these are the scenes of
daily life.
While they are scenes of daily life with the decodeable as transformational
activities.
So anything that you do,
and boy,
you're doing marshal,
you have arts.
This is a highly developed skill.
You will are somebody that you wouldn't be if you were,
didn't have that scale.
If you were doing a podcast and what you did for a living was flipping burgers
at Mcdonald's,
you wouldn't be Joe Rogan.
The you've,
you've,
you've been doing your homework without maybe even thinking that it was
homework.
Cause any,
anything that you're involved in that,
that you go at with a quest for perfection of whatever it is,
has this transformational value.
And when you recognize,
when you know it,
let's say,
when you know it intellectually,
when you can articulate it,
it doesn't,
it,
it implements the actually the activity itself.
So it's possible even to do that.
You could be an,
or you could be an enlightened Burger flipper and the Sophie's are very good at,
you know,
the Sufi is
in life,
but not as inland.
Why sorry is in life but not have it.
In other words,
you can,
you can practice waking up as it were in the midst of the most mundane thing you
could be.
You could,
you could be an enlightened garbage,
garbage collector as long as you knew what you were doing.
It's a totally different thing.
I would imagine.
I'm not a garbage collector.
That's a totally different thing to collect the garbage consciously than it is
to just do it resentfully because that's the only job that they can get all,
uh,
so when,
when we're talking,
it's,
it's not as though this is,
it's not as though this is
anything actually new.
It's as the oldest idea that ever was and it's something that people have been
doing for thousands and thousands of years.
Oh,
I had hunted
around that area previously and so I knew there was elk in the area.
Um,
I just had never been that far back in before.
And I'll tell you to tell you the truth,
it,
and nearly completely failed on me because I went days and days about here and
I'll see,
you know,
an elk.
But the sign was there to say that we're in,
in there,
it's just that the grizzlies and the,
the walls were hunting that area so hard that had shut the fuck up and push a
lot of them out of the area.
Yeah.
And then all those Neilia new food source.
So
wow.
So when you get in there and you don't see anything for a couple of days,
like what,
what is the mindset like?
What do you mean?
There's heaps of doubt and there's always that.
It's like you second guess yourself.
This was a Steven move.
You shouldn't have came in here.
You need to change spots.
But then it's like,
but at the same time,
your experience in this for a reason,
and this is how hunting should be,
hunting should be hard.
You should hunting should never be,
unless you've done your research going into a place and there's just like gain
walking past everywhere.
There should always be cause that's the hunt,
right?
Right.
Finding it or going through the hardship to find it,
tracking it,
fondant,
find them.
Where's the better spot within that area.
So at the same time that my is like,
you know,
you've made a bad decision.
This is a crap spot to be.
There's the whole experience of lock nut.
This is how hunting should be.
It should be difficult.
You should have to work your ass off to try and find the animal.
And when you actually do find the animal,
how much better is it?
Because you know,
it's just like if you haunted for 11 months and you didn't say a bowl,
you found a boy,
you had a shot in your missed.
But then the next one you get,
how good is that next one that you get?
You know,
if that was the case,
and it was very similar on this trip where I put in all that effort,
didn't see an animal.
One opportunity,
a bull comes in.
Oh,
I ended up calling that bull from like a mile away.
You can just hearing coming up this canyon and I did that shot and dude,
I tee it up.
I was crying because I knew how much had gone into it.
You know,
and it's not just the effort,
but you know,
like obviously I'm,
I'm away from my wife Kim and the kids.
I'm away from the kids for a month now.
There's all that sacrifice is all the hard shit.
There's all the effort.
There's walking in,
there's putting up with that absolutely atrocious weaver.
And then finally one opportunity comes up and you kill that animal as well as
kill an animal.
That's a hard thing to do,
man.
I bowled up.
I was crying like I think I cried a dozen times.
Every time I thought about it when I was standing over the ball,
I was crying.
Wow.
And I'm like,
that's why it's got to be that hard.
So you can appreciate their animal.
So you realize what has to go into the hunt to actually get something killed.
Should I think every hunt should be like that.
I hope they're not.
Well,
there's,
there's a lot of elk.
Yeah.
Okay.